so Sandra bist du bereit für die Hölle
willst du es anzünden wie dir das findet
man an ja man muss das Anzünden
[Musik]
ich bin so gespannt ich war wir waren ja
noch einmal hier in der Hölle
wir sind drin
wir sind drin oh mein Gott oh mein Gott
ich dachte Fall direkt runter
oh mein Gott
Sandy pass auf pass auf pass auf hier
über Lava was ich dir vorhin noch
beibringen wollte war es Nieten
ist wenn du die Shift-Taste gedrückt
hältst kennst du die Shift-Taste
das ist die Taste mit der doch aus dem
Boot aussteigen
mach das mal
guck mal dann siehst du aus wie ich
jetzt schon mal an so ach so okay und so
kannst du jetzt wenn du die Taste
gedrückt hältst ganz nah hier an den
Abgrund laufen macht das mal und kannst
einfach durchlaufen dann fällst du nicht
runter weißt du
okay und wenn du dann aber am Abgrund
stehst und dann ist die Taste loslässt
dann fällst du runter macht das jetzt
besser nicht am Abgrund dann musst du
erstmal zurück sneaken wieder genau und
dann loslassen okay sehr gut wie komme
oder das ist eine Festung
und was ist das denn
du kleiner Sohn oh mein Gott ey Sandra
ich wusste ganz genau wo ich dich
hinschubse also wir bauen uns jetzt mal
rüber in die Festung würde ich sagen ich
kann nicht mehr diese äußern ja ich baue
uns aber hier ganz vorsichtig gerade
lang also es kann gerade kann uns
eigentlich nichts passieren
wir haben eine Festung erzielt wir haben
auch den Erfolg okay ganz vorsichtig ich
gehe schon mal als erstes rein
Befestigung gut der Festung ist gut dann
Festung ist das einzige korrigiert mich
bitte im Chat falls ich falsch liege auf
eine Festung ist doch wirklich das
Einzige was man eigentlich braucht oder
für die Blase Drops siehst du die
dahinten der ist auch Skelett
die schießt uns ab Achtung Handy lauf
lauf lauf lauf lauf
[Musik]
hast du essen dann ist dein Essen okay
sehr gut
lauf lauf lauf lauf lauf lauf nein
ich habe mir nur das Geld ich kann das
Töten benutzt ein Schild
[Musik]
einfach niemanden angreifen wo bist du
wo bist du wo bist ich komme zu dir
von ihm zum goldenen Ding angegriffen
und bin tot
[Musik]
Luca ich wurde von zwei angegriffen
einer von vorne und einer von hinten
als allererstes nimmst du jetzt dein
Bett und stellst das vielleicht mal hier
so in die Ecke irgendwo rein
damit Du hier halt immer wieder spawnst
jetzt Rechtsklick einmal drauf dass du
einmal drin steht
[Musik]
Laser luca
ist dir auch eine Brücke wo bist du
ja ich pisse mir in die Hose Luca
[Musik]
die ganze Zeit
ich gebe dir jetzt mal Wassereimer
mach damit mal vor dich auf dem Boden
dass wir ein bisschen Wasser haben denn
wenn wir brennen können wir uns damit
quasi dann wieder löschen weißt du wie
ich meine also den Wasser einmal in die
Hand nehmen
irgendwie ist das Wasser verschwunden
nein
habe ich jetzt verkackt
eigentlich nicht mehr schaffen
wenn die essen essen laufen um die Ecke
laufen die Ecke in unseren Raum erst
sonst
[Musik]
zurück in unseren Raum warum läufst du
dann noch weiter vor
oh
[Musik]
nice
da oben ist der Spawner
und dann
muss man nur warten bis sie kommen und
dann muss man die töten ein paar
Sekunden
Schild benutzen zur Not
[Musik]
Scheiße nein Mist wahrscheinlich
sehr gut sehr sehr gut
[Musik]
aber erstmal stark mit der Hand oder
weiter weiter weiter weiter weiter kommt
laufen
warum bist du aus großer Höhe gefallen
wo bist du denn hingefallen komplett aus
ich gucke gerade im Stream dein Stream
ja ja jetzt gucke ich in meinem Stream
Sandra Stream wie sie meinen Stream
guckt
vier mal nein
[Musik]
wann gehen wir da nicht hin Laser weißt
du was das hier ist
das hier ist Sebastian was bedeutet das
ja das sind zu Hause
wir sind ziemlich starke Gegner
raus
oh das klappt ja gar nicht
[Musik]
hat Angst vor mir gehabt besser ist das
moin Moin ich würde sagen wir gehen mal
wieder raus hier ich sag dir meine
Anspannung war gerade auf eine
Milliarden glaub es mir ich war so
verkrampft in den Händen weil ich Angst
hatte zu sterben weil ich so viel Gold
gesammelt habe krass Handy sehr gut du
hast auf jeden Fall einiges heute
gelernt auch wenn du ein paar mal
gestorben bist fand ich es doch sehr
sehr sehr nice Portal haben wir
geschafft wir sind einmal gestorben also
ich zumindest das ist sehr sehr gut ich
habe 34 Level es war sehr sehr cool in
der Hölle ja Leute danke euch auf jeden
Fall für den Support ich bedanke mich
wirklich es war sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr sehr schön
[Musik]